[Music]
[Applause]
Devon mccordi he is a studio analyst for
NBC football night in America won three
Super Bowls with the Patriots and uh he
did work Black Friday with his brother
and I an eagle it was the Dolphins and
the Jets he joins us now Devon if you
didn't get paid to watch the Jets and
the Dolphins would you have watched the
Jets and the Dolphins
I would have probably caught a quarter
or two then I'd have found something
else to do what stood out in that
game I mean it was obviously the H marry
interception but just that phase like
we're watching the game and two of
throws an interception uh pick six the
Jets go score they miss the extra point
Miami gets the ball back Tua throws
another interception only for the Jets
to throw a hell marry that gets like
three interceptions and we we looked at
the clock it was 58 seconds after the
big six so all of this happened within a
minute in a game and then the rest of
the game was just it is what it is there
was no not much excitement after that
the Dolphins are interesting I just
don't know how good they are do you I I
think that's everybody's thing like we
know how they're going to perform
against the teams that are subpar below
they show up they usually handle
business but against the better teams
and it's not that they go and get blown
out they just fall short against the
better teams and it makes you Wonder
like okay do they really believe that
they can get over the hump if there's a
game down the stretch in December
against a good team or they getting the
playoff battle have they built up enough
equity as a team that they know all
right we're in the middle of the fourth
quarter we're going to execute and win I
don't know if they have that belief
about themselves yet would you be scared
or how scared of Tua would you be as a
defensive back I would be scared I you
know for my time competing against Tua
for one I never beat him was time in
Miami but when he's in that offense he's
Elite and you know I think he gets a lot
of criticism but the times he's been
hurt and guys have had to step up and
play in that offense it hasn't looked
the same you know whether they've had
Tyreek or Jaylen Wadd out there other
quarterbacks haven't been able to make
that offense look the way that it looks
when he's there so if you have to play
that offense it's not an easy like we're
going to go do this and do that and shut
them out even though I think defenses
have played better you know now going
down the stretch but it's still scary
playing against a offense uh with to
handling and running the show okay give
me your perspective as a former
defensive back of you're facing Jaylen
Herz what are you concerned
about that he's going to make the
winning play I mean for Buffalo and that
defense at one point um you know in the
first half like Jaylen herst had 50
yards passing like we're we're watching
the game and we're in studio so we're
still live and working but you me and
Chris Sims are looking at the stats I'm
like he has 50 yards passing then gets
up to you know I think 170 yards and
like buffalo's defense is doing but then
you get to the clutch moments in the
game he's rolling left two yards from
out of bounds throws a beautiful ball
over top of puyer in high and hit zakus
in the back of the end zone like that's
a clutch play so it it reminded me a
little bit of when you play like Tom
Brady and those guys they could have a
bad day but you always knew like if it
got to that point in the game where you
had to make a play or they had to make a
play more than likely were going to make
the play and Jaylen Hurst is starting to
develop that this season but it feels
like he knows he doesn't have to make
every play but Josh Allen it feels like
he thinks he has to make every play so
your your game plan with Josh Allen how
different would that be facing him as
opposed to Jaylen Herz yeah and it feels
like that because it kind of it is that
Josh Allen does have to make those plays
for this team to win the scrambles the
five pump fakes and make a guy Miss like
he has to make those plays where think
Jaylen Hurst does he goes into the game
and he looks around him and he goes hey
like I have First Team all pros at a lot
of different positions on this team I
don't need to make that crucial mistake
that hurts our team because somebody
else will make the play where Josh Allen
is sitting there and I thought he did a
great job in the game like he was
patient he took what the defense gave
him but then you still looked up and you
were like wow this is still a close game
like they haven't put this team away and
some of that was you know they miss a
field goal like all those little things
that show up put more and more pressure
on Josh Allen and we criticized the one
interception he threw to Bradberry but
it's like he he made one mistake in a
game where he had to be great time after
time that's hard to do and it it it
stinks because they still haven't
released some of that burden from Josh
Allen still after all of these years
with him performing so high we hear
analysts say this about the receiver
went the wrong way Gabe Davis last night
as a defensive back do you like the
receiver has the ability to go either
left or right like he can and then the
quarterback has to adapt like how does
that work where you're trying to cover
somebody and he's kind of deciding what
he wants to do based off how you're
playing him yeah and on that play you
saw like Philadelphia was in Blitz zero
they W an all out Blitz everybody had a
man and you see slay they're up there
trying to disrupt timing because they
know the pressure is going to get there
and usually as an offense you all have
to see the picture the same way and it
was interesting because as we're
watching and they're cutting away to the
guys on the sideline you see Gabe Davis
and Diggs talking and they're going back
and forth and then it looks like Gabe
Dave says something to digs and he goes
oh damn almost like oh that's what
happened I kind of see why you broke
outside because of what you thought the
defensive back gave you and to me that's
just one of those things where the blitz
worked the timing was thrown off Josh
Allen's thinking I'm is going to get
this ball up Gabe Davis is just going to
run and go and Gabe Davis is thinking
like I'm going to get off the line of
scrimmage and I'm going to break out to
the corner route and that little bit of
kind of undecisive I think was caused by
the blitz so Philadelphia's defense did
a good job on that play you Devon
mccordi works for football night in
America on NBC three-time Super Bowl
champ with the Patriots how does it work
getting Tom Brady's number when you play
for the Patriots can you ask or does Tom
give you his number
um I asked but I didn't ask right away I
I didn't have his number for years and
then eventually I asked but I do
remember one time we had a big group
chat we were talking about something and
Adam Butler who plays for the Las Vegas
Raiders now he was a young guy and he
saw Tom text and he was like Tom Brady
is that you and Tom was like yeah he go
Tom tells him to save his number text
him anytime and like he was floored and
now he had Brady's number but if you're
asking Brady for his number is it like
asking a girl for her number it kind of
feels like that it's a it's that like am
I good enough to ask Tom like almost
like hey is this girl just out of my
league is she a little too cute but
super down to earth so it always works
out for guys yeah he could have given
you a fake
number um let me ask you about the teams
who can win a Super Bowl in the AFC how
many teams do you think truly can win a
Super
Bowl I mean you obviously you gotta have
Baltimore in there
um Kansas City because of momes I think
they're they're always in it um and I
would also throw Jacksonville in there I
think the way Jacksonville has performed
I think you you got to put them um in
that category um and then out of the AFC
East like we talked about before I'm
just not sold on Miami yet being able to
be over that hump but if you said if you
said to me right now in a world can you
see my yeah I would I would say Miami is
in that b and you know I think for the
AFC North who had the strongest division
the injuries I think takes everybody
else out of that category um to be able
to win win a Super Bowl but um I think
momes is the wild card because if the
team gets up to Pace he's the best
quarterback to me in the NFL and when
you have that guy I think you have the
best odds to win a Super Bowl okay how
many teams in the NFC can win a Super
Bowl an NFC I think
it's obviously Philadelphia I think San
Francisco I think Dallas um I don't I
don't think Detroit is in that category
I know their records still up there
they're still going to be one of the
better teams I'm not sold on Detroit
being able to execute and win down the
stretch um to win a Super Bowl how many
quarterbacks had a tell you can say it
now since you're not playing but did you
could you know have an idea of that
they're going to pass or he's going to
throw it my way snap count I mean
anything like that stand out with any
quarterback um not to like just say
definitely like this guy but it to me it
was always like an whole offense thing
it wasn't just like I remember we had a
beat that we thought on Aaron roders in
2018 December game in New England so you
know everybody's wearing their pouches
and we get in at halftime and they're
like Aaron Rogers has his hands in his
pouch and then he takes him out right
before he snaps the ball and I'm kind of
looking like this is Mickey Mouse like
this is Aaron roders we're gonna really
go off so we're like doing these allout
blitzes like we have all these things
and in the first half we're just looking
at the play clock because Aaron Rogers
is good like it's and we go out there in
the second half he takes his hands out
he gives us the fake and he just Smiles
at us we all take off full speed and
he's ear to ear smiling like I got y'all
now and for the rest of the game like
that tail went just like that that's
great that was always a scary thing
against the really good guys that's
great if Bill bellich called and said
Devin you think I should continue to
coach what would you say I would say yes
um
in New England we would have a long
conversation if it about if it's in New
England um I think you know I remember
you know talking to coach sheno back at
Ruckers Greg sheno about when you're in
one place for a long time sometimes it's
time for a change I think we saw that
with Brady a few years ago goes down to
Tampa wins the Super Bowl I think in New
England like it it could possibly be
that time for bill so that first
question I would answer in 5 seconds but
the rest of our conversation will
probably go on for about three hours
of trying to decide and talk about the
pros and cons of being and staying in
New England what if Robert Craft called
you and said Devon what do you think I
should do at the coaching position it'
be the same thing it' be a long
conversation because you don't just move
on from Bill bich I think we live in a
world now that we go strictly off the
results on the field right now but my
whole thing is if you fire Bill bich who
comes in next that you say I guarantee
this guy gives me a better chance or
woman gives me a better chance next
season to be better than bill bich would
um I think that's the hard thing I think
the ball is really in Bill's Court of
where he wants to be and what he wants
to do um I think if if I'm running the
team and I give Mr craft advice I I
don't think it would ever be hey you
need to move on and fire coach bellich
all right before I let you go Tom Brady
came out and talked about the state of
football now and it's you know the
quality is not what it was when he
played which is such a long time ago
like two years ago Tom and then Alex
Smith on NFL Sunday countdown on the
Mother Ship had this to say about Tom
Brady do you agree with Tom Brady I a
lot here Sam listen first off let me
just prep I love Tom the goat but you
don't need to say that but you say just
kid first off he hasn't been retired
that long he was just playing like he
just won a Super Bowl in the current
game like is he discounting that one um
and then my my biggest complaint with
this and and no offense you guys well
all three of you guys he played in the
most uncompetitive division I think in
NFL history I mean you come out of
training camp the biggest cupcake
division you got a ticket to the
playoffs right away like talk about
mediocre like I I completely disagree
with this I I know I know he's he's
referencing the rule change all right I
mean it is a fair point the AFC E's not
that competitive there
Devin it is but the the hard thing
whenever you talk about Brady you pull
up his record against any other division
you want to pull up against the AFC
North the AFC West like he he went and
dominated um but I thought it was funny
because some of the rule changes like
roughing a passer was an ultimate
benefit for the pocket passer like a
Brady that sat in the pocket but we
always I mean I've talked to him at
length about that like we would watch
plays where a guy would throw it over
the middle and the guy would get smoked
and they throw a flag 15 yard penalty
and his first thing the first thing he
would say is it's not the defenser
that's not the defender's fault that's
that's the quarterback like he can't
throw that ball over there and I think
when he said those comments I think
that's exactly the things he was
thinking about seeing these guys get
penalties get suspended get fined for
hits that for a long time when we used
to sit in the meetings we would say Ray
Lewis is going to be in the middle of
the field and Bill would tell Tom if you
throw it over there Wes is going to be
in the hospital we're GNA next week so
you won't have him next week so if you
want them next week for the game you
better make sure you don't throw it to
him right over the middle did you ever
smoke Tom
Brady I didn't I didn't we had an allout
Blitz in in 21 where we played Tampa and
just as I was getting to him he threw
and and he looked at me he goes Dev
really you gonna go zero against me and
I just turned around and went back to
the Huddle because I was like this
reminds me of many of our battles and
practice and somehow you still
win hey great to catch up with you thank
you for joining us Devon we appreciate
it thanks good talking to you Dan that's
Devon McCord NBC football night in
America analyst won three Super Bowls
with the Patriots and uh three time all
pro